bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt franck alors comment
accueillez vous cette décision d'ajouter
c'est extrêmement regrettable puisque
nous sommes en période de confinement
donc les riverains sont contraints de
rester grands partis chez eux et malgré
cela on diminue les distances d'épandage
et on n'arrive pas à convaincre le
conseil d'état qu'il ya vraiment une
urgence à agir
le conseil d'état ne se prononce pas sur
le fond il y voit là je ne peux pas je
ne vous donne pas raison parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'urgence à agir
alors que là nous semble en tout début
de démarrage des épandages de pesticides
en milieu devra du fait du coc vie 19 il
a donc été permis à de déroger au droit
en ce qui concerne cette distance de
d'épandage est ce que c'était justifié
selon vous non seulement ce n'est pas
justifié les ces criminels parce qu'à
partir du moment où il ya un confinement
partir du moment où les gens ne peuvent
pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas quitter leur
domicile
il aurait fallu faire l'inversé surtout
ne pas réduire des distances
d'éloignement des pesticides qui sont
déjà très ridicule 3 m 5000 10 m
seulement mais dangereuses étaient des
produits et la non seulement au maintien
les produits mais en plus on réduit la
distance des habitations qui peut
comprendre ça quel citoyen peut
comprendre ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez
pragmatique vous êtes vous contre tout
emploi de produits phytopharmaceutiques
oui d'accord ce sont des pesticides
nécessite ça veut dire tu es le vivent
cette expression mais c'est maintenant
de parler de médicaments des plantes on
essaie de d'atténuer un peu cette notion
de dangerosité
aujourd'hui les pesticides sont on
remarque si vous voulez que des maladies
professionnelles des agriculteurs sont
aussi les maladies des riverains et qu'
il y a là des choses très très
inquiétante pour la santé publique
sans compter bien entendu la
biodiversité qui disparaît ce serait les
abeilles les papillons les chenilles et
c'est donc ces pesticides qui sont une
chimie qui tue le vivant doit être
réduite de façon très très importante
c'est une question de santé publique et
de biodiversité pour la évoqués ou au
contraire aujourd'hui les concertations
entre les agriculteurs et les riverains
on
il n'y a pas de concertation si vous
voulez parce que on essaye d'imposer les
chartes qui sont en fait des chartes dit
de bon voisinage mais qui n'ont aucune
contrainte pour les agriculteurs et qui
sont en fait simplement des chartes dans
lesquels on s'engage à respecter ce
qu'il ya sur des bidons de pesticides
sur les bidons de pesticides et indiquer
les choses extrêmement dangereuse pour
la santé comme par exemple à partir d'un
épandage qui a été fait on demande à
l'agriculteur surtout de ne pas
retourner dans son chant parfois jusqu'à
plusieurs heures après d'épandage ce qui
montre la dangerosité des produits dans
la concertation est extrêmement
difficile parce que d'un côté les avez
les agriculteurs qui dit oui mais nous
on est autorisé ces normands et de
l'autre côté vous avez des riverains qui
disent oui mais ils vous rendent manque
peut-être mais notre santé d'abord donc
c'est très vite
il faudra une loi générale je pense pour
dire voilà dans intenté donné quatre
cinq ans par exemple
nous prenons l'engagement collectif des
les agriculteurs à se passer des
pesticides de synthèse
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions daniel cueff
maire de langoat en ille-et-vilaine
président du collectif de mères anti
pesticides